So next game of Royal Master from
Canada
I've played that a lot too,
so I have in the
back of my mind that you
get Catalan here and
then you take it away, yes, we've
actually done that a few times, but now
I've slept, I want to  Actually there's
A4 to prevent this B5 story,
it's not really
bad or anything for white but I
just forgot, yes,
okay, um so
C4 now follows bishop A6 and
knight E5 comes so that the four there
he can actually give the quality here
I saw that recently
in the game Gel found against
and white
got very good compensation,
it's often like that when you
can do something on the finish line
so
he goes with the queen here somehow
after G6  So
yeah, you don't know anymore, you can
maybe even swap and jump 5. I
don't know if that's enough compensation. The
alternative would be E4 to say you put
your queen there strangely
A5 an idea,
make four
so knight 55
or that just falls C6 let's take a
look
and knight i5 is clear but I have
bishop F4 for example
then he actually doesn't have a
smart move
knight simply C6 is very
unpleasant because he is the bishop because he
can  maximum to C5
although there are 5 here he can also ne go
three hangs then
I haven't seen it
hurts me eight years
maybe well
I just find it very unpleasant if
he then if he then really
goes
down to C5 but with that trip goes immediately
maybe runner E3  First of all, age
maybe C5 really directly, no, I do
n't know, it doesn't help that black
works well, it has five, I think it's too big or I
want to take it,
so
now I'm going to jump here,
six probably doesn't bring that many anymore
I'm still here now with
compensation, it's a really good question,
so I want to cover it with
playing E5, maybe
he says that's no problem, yes, he can
be right about that,
well, but I can also go on and on,
playing on compensation,
pregnant  you six is ​​a possibility
or on toom D8 Spinner C6 so I
'm still quite active here
it's not a sure-fire success for
Black,
maybe now also in five okay,
he's already taken that, he's taken it
so you can now take it to the knight
or take it with what  you now
come with the queen knight E5 then let's
take
away six times
I have to play a little calmly
so at least in terms of
positioning let's say
here you have the compensation is now
here in the long term if at all
I could have played but
maybe it was  quite good to get the knight
away from the six of us
unfortunately not because B6 can go so e.g.
E5 takes takes knight bishop Edith
rook and then okay yes there prevents
so and now the question is how do
we continue now
knight B8 C6 could be an idea for
Black,
I could also play knight D6 now
and then the whole
row comes in.
He then has C4 but can he hold that? Yes, it
's interesting, let's try it.
He has such a strange
position here with the queen being
the one  never plays with no, yes, that's what
I thought too, but I actually thought
Queen A4 would be
an idea back then
Moves here probably
look somehow cramped, I
still don't recognize it here
because the seven is hanging out because
A7 is out.
You could also take B4 but
the arm farmer
also looks tempting
so
okay
so yes knight the four no but good
now he has to run here
like that  and then taken
nothing more they do but
I have it but man
yes I think it was a good game
so well probably the
computer is laughing at you but it
was an interesting compensation position I think
he had real problems the
queen is always stupid on G6 and you
had  always pressure on the gut wing yes what
I closer analysis
shows maybe something different but
I think it looked quite good for one intended for
a blitz game,
black was able
to defend itself better but it was clearly an unpleasant
position